foreign
we're starting a little bit early on
this uh crisp Saturday no longer morning
almost noon with the AMA because I see
I've already got a lot of uh questions
lined up so I may as well kick it off
get this thing started
um here's a good question to begin with
and this is something I actually have a
very definite answer to it's from Kyle
do you recommend watching a core concept
video before or after reading the
primary text I think that people should
try to take a stab at reading the text
before looking for resources in general
it could be a core concept video it
could be any other kind of video it
could be a blog post you shouldn't
deprive yourself
of the opportunity to you know see for
yourself what's actually in a text so I
just shot some some videos this morning
on Thomas Aquinas dealing with uh The
Passion of anger
um you should read the summative logia
and see what he has to say before going
to find core concept videos in part
there's a couple reasons one is you
shouldn't deprive yourself of the
opportunity to engage primary texts
full-on and then use whatever resources
are going to be helpful for you and
imagine too that there's going to be
like a read use a resource go back and
read again with a deeper understanding
but you know there's there's other
reasons too I would say you know you
don't know unless you've actually like
read the text whether the person is is
bullshitting you or not whether they you
know take stoicism for example there's
like hundreds of thousands of videos out
there by people who really don't know
much about stoicism at all and how do
you know that they're actually
representing Seneca or Epictetus or
Marcus Aurelius correctly if you haven't
actually read the text so
I think that's that's quite uh important
uh the bicameral monk asks do you like
weird fiction as a genre I'm talking
about Lovecraft and lagoti and writers
like that yeah I like I like weird
fiction quite a bit I I like a lot of
speculative fiction you know fantasy
sci-fi horror uh alternate uh histories
dystopia Utopia weird fits in there they
all kind of they've all got
interconnections with each other
and part of what I've been reading
lately I mean I am a big fan of of
Lovecraft I can't say that I've actually
read much lagoti
although I I probably should you know
sometime down the line
um but you know we could think about
Clark Ashton Smith or uh is it Chambers
who wrote the the King in Yellow you
know
um all of that that sort of stuff fits
in there and I've read a lot of like
recent
lovecraftian stuff that I I think is is
quite good as well I think it's cool
that there's like a whole universe open
to people to write
in there so yeah I like that uh Galen
have you read much of the desert fathers
and if so how would you compare and
contrast them with the stoics with
respect to guidance about managing and
taking the passions so first the first
thing I'll say is
you shouldn't think in terms of the
desert fathers
um there are these like sayings of the
desert fathers but what do we actually
know about the desert fathers from
actual authors
who could have been a desert father or
you know just studied with them I mean
we probably know the most from evagrius
ponticus and John Cassian I would say
you know and then there's there's others
as well but
um calling them the desert fathers you
know is kind of a I mean you want to
like say the desert fathers and Cassian
and devagris and you know athanasius and
Gregory of nice and you know you want to
be like you got you want to have these
these people in your mind the real
sources not just sayings of the the
desert fathers which is a fine book but
you know doesn't really cover the the
gamut and yeah I mean I do work on John
Cassian and of Agri as ponticus so yeah
I've I've read these guys
um they you know they adopted some
things from the stoics uh Margaret
Graver makes a great case in stoicism
and emotion that avagreus ponticus is in
many respects taking
um you know stoic ideas about the
cognitive aspects of emotions and
weaving them in
one thing that you can say
and this is very very clear navagris and
in the conferences and Institutes of of
John Cassian is that while the stoics
had an anthropology that with a few
exceptions you know Seneca is is an
exception to this at points and it
appears that maybe posidonius and
panatius were as well
um it's got one main part of the soul
that does the the working right the
the rational part extends pretty far the
you know the not just the desert fathers
but most early Christian authors
are in effect when it comes to the sole
platonists
um and what I mean by that is that they
accept that there's three main parts to
the human soul besides you know the
vegetative Parts there's the rational or
you know the rational part you know the
mind right
um
uh hey logike and then there's the
appetite the epithumia right which are
multiple and very often unruly and then
there's this middle part the spirited or
as I've seen it translated in the
philocalia the incandescent part the
sumatic part so that's a very important
distinction between you know a platonist
point of view which gets incorporated
into these early Christian authors and
uh stoic point of view on the emotions
but I would also say
you know the stomachs did recognize some
positive emotions the uh monastic
authors I would say recognize more of
these and you know you don't have to be
a Egyptian desert father Syrian desert
father to to uh discuss this look at
Augustine and his discussion of the
emotions and
um
I forget which book it's in but in
um
city of God right where he's talking
about the stoics and how they got
emotions partly right and partly wrong
so I think that's that's part of uh it
uh Mark hey Mark good to see you here he
says congrats on your recent Twitter
milestone
uh question is thoughts on a virtue
ethics approach to a philosophy of the
Oikos meaning the household or I suppose
we could consider it the relations that
the household has with other
um institutions educational political
you know economic
any thinkers or texts you'd recommend in
this regard take care and have an
awesome AMA
um any thinkers or texts I would
recommend I mean there's so many right I
mean there's there's a lot of reflection
on this in ancient philosophy
already in you know the platonic
tradition and Aristotle has a book uh
which may or may not be Aristotle that
awakenomike right
economics it's translated it means
household management and he's got
remarks on that in other places like the
politics and the nick of McCain ethics
um you know the stoics had some stuff to
say about this
um the epicureans probably had stuff to
say but we've lost so many of their
texts that we don't really know then
there's like you know plenty of
Christian authors who are concerned with
the relationship between the family or
the house and and the state and then you
know as we move on into modernity I
would say this never really goes away
and although we don't teach this stuff
too often in philosophy classes there's
many many discussions about domestic
life and what it does look like and what
it should look like and how it's
connected with these other domains of
human existence
so you know think about Mary
Wollstonecraft and her her uh
condemnation of the idea that men should
be given a public education and women
should be given a domestic education and
the inequalities that this not only
represents and fosters but also the
cycle of perpetuating that you know
um I think that's that's you know she'd
be somebody to to look at and there's
there's so many other authors that I
don't really know where I would start if
I had to like organize a class on it so
yeah so um let's see what we've got next
um
so buy uh baisus says have you ever
thought about making some in-depth core
concept Style videos about Maurice
Blondell
yeah I mean I've thought about it I
thought about in-depth core concept
videos on many people it's just a matter
of getting to the people you know with
the amount of time that I have on my
hands
um usually when I'm creating core
concept videos it's it's oriented by the
classes that I'm currently teaching and
so you know that's that's an important
thing to keep in mind so you're probably
not going to see
too many things on Blown Dell right away
but you know I'll do some stuff on
Blondell down the line I have a client
who had me reading
with him history and Dogma so that might
be a good one to to start with
um
there's other you know short pieces that
might be good if I ever do get around to
shooting core concept videos on the
Christian philosophy debates obviously
there will be a lot on blown out because
when I translated his his works I
included four of them in the volume uh
of of translations you know reason
fulfilled by Revelation the 1930s
Christian philosophy debates in France
um and I you know I enjoy reading him I
did my dissertation on him because I
like him so much but he's a tricky
thinker so I I would need to clear some
space and time I suppose to be up to
that
Dale has studying mathematics affected
the way you think in any way yeah
obviously I mean because uh studying
mathematics you know for all of us from
you know kindergarten through to 12th
grade uh teaches us things about
mathematics like the Pythagorean theorem
right that's affecting how you think in
in some way because now you've got
something stored away in your head that
you can you can use
um I think probably what you're asking
is not that sort of very general
question but you're asking like
what has studying mathematics at a
higher level done for you I mean
obviously if you're interested in
approaching things you could say in
terms of formal logic and formal
structures and stuff like that it's good
to study mathematics because you develop
a sort of
um
habit of mind that is connected with
that you know
um if you take a discrete math class in
college for example you're actually
going to do some truth tables and some
other cool stuff as well like graph
Theory and you know matters like that
and I I you know I would say that one of
the things that you do learn very
quickly
is about
the non-coincidence between formal
systems including those of mathematics
and the reality that's that's out here
which is much Messier and more
complicated
and so in a way not only do you learn
like a mathematical logical approach to
things you also learn the limits of that
which I think is very important because
there's a lot of people who
think that if they can just put a couple
numbers together they've got metrics and
now suddenly that means something right
so yeah that's that's kind of helpful I
mean if I think back to my college math
classes
I really enjoyed
um the Cal classes I went you know calc
one two and three
um thinking about measuring rates of
change which is essentially what
calculus is is about you know there's
lots of other things involved in it as
well but that's like the the most
fundamental
you know idea that's that's a really
cool idea and it helps you to look at
things in the world in a different way
so when people are throwing stats at you
you can be like this is really
messy and inconclusive stuff that you're
putting here in this infographic you
know so I think that that's kind of
helpful
uh Eamon Tucker thoughts on Arthur F
Holmes I don't know who Arthur F Holmes
is
um apparently he's got an 81 video
series for Wheaton on the history of
philosophy seems quite knowledgeable but
I'm not educated enough to know I I
don't know either
Wheaton is an Evangelical school that
does have a a
what do you call this confessional
statement
so you can expect that he's going to be
approaching things certainly with
Christianity and not any old
Christianity because you can't be a
Catholic at Wheaton
um although I think you you can get away
with being Eastern Orthodox
because Wheaton is a little bit
inconsistent with that or used to be in
the past so you know it's going to be a
Protestant uh
Evangelical probably low Church approach
to things and you know I I don't know I
don't know the guy at all so
you know you'd have to take a look at
them uh uros in one of your earlier
videos I think you mentioned you're not
a fan of Spinoza what do you dislike
about his philosophy notice that the two
things are very different not being a
fan of somebody is very neutral
um we're not fans of tons and tons of
people right it's not as if we're
automatically fans of people just
because other people are fans of them
then dislike about his philosophy
um I think that Spinoza
made his his uh ethics unduly
Complicated by the in in perspective
rather silly formulations that he's
using uh you know there's more a
geometrico which Hobbes also did in
Spinoza probably got some of this
spindles it takes a lot from Hobbes as
well as from Descartes you know
um but this does not make things clear
at all it just makes things way more
complicated because you have to figure
out what the hell is he actually trying
to say so I'm not a fan of that mode of
presentation but you notice that in his
other works uh Spinoza doesn't always do
that right
I also find his view on God and
substance just implausible and you know
I'm not attracted to uh monisms of
various sorts
and uh I think he's kind of he's one of
these people who like Hegel or like
others you know they're they're
important but you don't necessarily have
to get into them and if you didn't like
ever read them in your life it's not as
if you you've missed understanding
philosophy as such they're just one of
many people and I think there's a lot of
Fanboys out there who don't actually
understand Spinoza well but his work has
kind of like an aura around it and I
just don't like that sort of thing you
know
um I think that makes for bad philosophy
so
um
you know that said I've taught Spinoza
in the past you know people are always
why don't you do some videos on Spinoza
you want me to do videos on Spinoza pay
for the videos commission them because I
got other stuff to do as well I mean I
would rather do stuff on Maurice
Blondell than on Spinoza and I haven't
even gotten to Blondell yet right so
you know there there's there's quite a
bit of that going on uh once they named
me I wasn't says do you like the king
and yellow uh yeah I like the the the
the book and I like the fact that other
people all the way down to the present
are still writing within that narrative
Universe which I think is a really cool
thing that's that's kind of a sign that
foreign
that has lasting power
narratively right
people want to not just write fan
fiction
um but really good fan fiction within
your your narrative universe and you
know like notice who is able to do that
and who wasn't HP Lovecraft you know
there's lots of
stuff out there some of it so so some of
it really quite good
um the king and yellow you know
that that has has given rise to that
Michael morcock by contrast the
Cornelius Chronicles not a lot of people
wanted to take that on and and work
within that that world
all right
um impulsive what sort of being the
animals have in Heidegger's view they're
clearly not Dawson but thinking about
them in terms of Readiness to hand or
Presence at hand seems strange well you
know the the cure for that is don't try
to
um shoehorn everything into there's only
three kinds of being you know dazine
ready at hand and Presence at hand uh
maybe there's more complicated kinds of
being in Heidegger than than just that
um animals are living things and I mean
Heidegger says things like they don't
have a world
and I think that's probably wrong you
know they they do have worlds they're
just different worlds than that which we
complicated uh messy things that we call
Dawson or human being have
um and maybe they are in some respects
you know less complex than ours but you
know they they certainly intersect with
ours when we have animals that we become
close with like you know for example I
did with our dogs and our cats
um particularly with sassy uh who uh
passed away about
half a year ago
we share a world we we share a life
world with each other now that life
world is a certainly in term rather than
Heidi Gary in term but
you know I don't I don't think that I
mean what the way I think that you're
looking at it is what kind of being do
they have for us not what kind of being
do they have per se right
um
DC stuns AZ 100 are the cardinal virtues
the foundations of all the other virtues
uh depends on who you ask
um they wouldn't be foundations for
those who who think that the cardinal
virtues are the right ones
they would be the sort of overarching
virtues that Encompass the others so
they're not foundations they're rather
like containers so if you think about
the stoics for example right
um four cardinal virtues wisdom Justice
Temperance courage what does courage
include depending on who you ask if it's
Aries did a mess or diogenes Laertes
anywhere or Cicero or anywhere from uh
two to five
sub-virtues of them and I think we could
correlate this and say that there's like
six or seven different ones
um
so yeah I mean if you have an account
like that
um then the cardinal virtues are indeed
you know you could if they're not
foundations they're foundational you
could say and that they or they are
encompassing
um but maybe there's some stuff that
gets left out you know maybe
like Aristotle thinks we need to treat
some of them some of the other virtues
as like their own thing like we need a
virtue specifically about anger or two
virtues specifically about handling
wealth or you know three virtues
handling social life
people try to you know connect these up
together that's part of the vast history
of ideas that involve the virtues and
moral philosophy in general so there
isn't there isn't a stock answer to that
you know
uh Bill Bob Baggins do you think movies
are good methods for philosophical
reflection totally depends on the movie
right and totally depends on
the kind of philosophical reflection
that you're after
um and I think you could say the same
thing about music too
so this is going to seem like a bit of a
digression but you know we saw Rage
Against the Machine at Alpine Valley
this summer along with run the jewels
and I was very struck
by a couple things about Rage Against
the Machine as we are watching the
performance so the first thing is
for a band that's supposed to be you
know talking about solidarity and stuff
like that
um they sure don't give a [ __ ] about
Their audience at all they they don't
Engage The Audience one bit which I
guess is their MO
which is a little weird right already a
little bit of a discrepancy
and then the other thing I realized as I
was watching like not just there's
there's stage show and listening to the
lyrics but watching the images behind
them
they're really kind of posers you know I
mean you could say to begin with they're
you know Tom Morella and I forget the
singer's name they're they're
millionaires right they've got tons and
tons of money and lots of social
Prestige uh so they're not they're not
among us but
the
the narratives that were being presented
are very very superficial
you know and you could use their their
lyrics and their songs as kind of
gateways into like more deep thinking or
you know action in terms of uh
solidarity resisting oppression and
stuff like that but on their own they're
really weak stuff you know and I think
that's the case for a lot of movies that
try to incorporate or TV shows that try
to incorporate philosophy there's
they're they're usually very
heavy-handed and reflective of like you
know basically reading Wikipedia and not
much else you know not not really
thinking through and engaging with ideas
and I I just guess this is the the case
in part
because of the way in which you know our
our we can call it the culture industry
you know the way in which they they
churn things out there's not a lot of
serious thinking encouraged
um there's a lot of appeal to like let's
let's do the tropes that work and you
know the exception would be like when
you're trying to win an Oscar and you
write a script but that's more about
like appealing to the emotions
than real serious thinking so movies can
be
movies can't be methods for
philosophical reflection except with
rare you know uh notable exceptions
but they can be Vehicles you can use the
movie like you know for example I used
to show dark city in intro to philosophy
class and Memento and we would discuss
things like memory and human identity
and you know the possibility of being
deceived by stuff these great you know
epistemological and metaphysical and
ethical issues but you got to be
bringing that to the the movie you know
so
all right uh
uh oldies do you think we can get
epistemological certainty about
empirical matters
uh I don't think it matters much because
I don't know too many people that are
going around what's my epistemological
certainty if you if you're if that's
what you're bringing to empirical
perceptual matters uh you're probably
setting up a problem for yourself that
you're not going to be able to resolve I
think the question is more like can we
be reasonably certain about some things
that are empirical sure yeah why not and
other things we can't and sometimes it
turns out that we were wrong about what
we thought we were certain about so I
think that's probably a
a better approach to it ridicule if you
read ordinary vices by Judith sklarb I
have not read ordinary vices by Judith
sklar uh as a matter of fact I don't
think I've read anything by her so
tractanus what are some of the best
objections to skepticism you know the
classics are that it's self-defeating
how do you Skeptics know that you can't
know anything that goes way the hell
back in the ancient philosophy
Epictetus I was just actually editing a
podcast where he's criticizing that
um
I mean it depends on what kind of
skepticism you're talking about
are you talking about like extreme
skepticism where people are saying ah we
can't know anything
um all knowledge is is uncertain or
something like that
that's you know fairly easy to refute
just by living an actual life uh if the
Skeptics were right you couldn't
actually like function in that respect
but if you're talking about Skeptics
like you know somebody like Cicero where
you notice that he's willing to take on
a whole bunch of stuff that he thinks is
probable because he's following
carneades and has skepticism
um I don't know that you need to refute
that I mean I guess the question that
you want to think about is why why worry
about whether other people are are
Skeptics you know or advancing
skepticism
why did logical empiricism fail
um fail in what sense you know I mean
any philosophical position that you take
you're going to find critics of it
um
you know maybe you could say it left out
too much stuff I mean James James is
before that but James is critical of the
people calling themselves empiricists
for not being empirical enough right so
oftentimes when you um when you rule
things out uh because it doesn't fit
your philosophical methodology you're
not being very philosophical right
uh Eunice says what translation of the
Bible do you recommend for non-religious
reading I I don't have a recommended
translation of the Bible there's many
translations out there if I if I'm
curious about what's going on in a
particular text if it's in the Christian
New Testament I just read the Greek you
know and that's you know that's also
basically what I do
um I just read this up too agent when it
comes to the earlier stuff some of which
was written in Greek book of wisdom you
know
um a few others as well
um but I I don't I don't get into
worries about translation I did a video
about for philosophical texts about
which translation is the best it totally
depends you know on on what you're
you're doing so
um Erickson Brown what do you think of
the strength and weakness of the second
argument from cause by Aquinas
um
I don't I don't find the five ways
particularly compelling but I also don't
worry an awful lot about apologetics or
arguments for God's existence as if
they're supposed to just convince on
their own they're always part of a
framework and a world view and I I think
Hegel is right that
in many respects he says this in the the
um lectures on the philosophy of
religion the real interesting thing
about the arguments for God God's
existence is not usually whether or not
they work it's what kind of viewpoint on
God do they provide us with and so if
you think about you know the arguments
from at least the first three well the
and the fifth way right the fourth way
is kind of kind of weird and wonky I
guess it is a causal argument but it's
really rather neoplatonist and its
Assumption of degrees of being and stuff
like that so you know you take the first
two
which are very much about causality not
yet about necessity and possibility like
the Third Way
um what kind of God do they give us
definitely the god of the philosophers
rather than as as you know somebody like
Kierkegaard or you know shustoff would
say the god of Abraham Isaac and Jacob
um
so you know do you buy into the
assumptions if you do well then I guess
they work for you you know
um if you say well maybe we could have
infinite regress
then they're obviously not going to work
right so a lot of these really depend on
where we're coming from rather than them
being a perfect
um
uh
proof or argument or something like that
Gregory asks is there a preferred copy
of Cicero's conspiracy of Catalan that
you recommend no
there is not again people are asking for
these recommendations and uh quite often
I don't have any you know
you
know
um I'm very pragmatic about these sort
of things
all right
um
Yoda what does objective versus
subjective mean exactly in philosophy
there's no answer to that I mean
this is the sort of thing where you want
to like start reading around and seeing
how people use these terms right
um Paul rakur has this great discussion
of good and bad subjectivity I forget it
might it might be in his um
conversation no it's not in his
conversations with Gabriel Marcel I
forget which work it's in but
um there isn't a mean exactly in
philosophy there's mean from this
perspective mean in this person's Works
mean in this person's works and so you
want to uh you want to look at that
ridicule asks where to look in stoic
text or other philosophy to read about
Temperance desire Temperance and desire
two two different things Temperance is a
virtue desire is a big encompassing term
which can mean the emotions involved in
it it can also mean the basic impulse
you know towards uh and which is you
know the opposite of that is aversion so
it really depends on what term of desire
you mean but if you want to know about
Temperance
um I got a whole video about each of the
stoic virtues uh from streams that I did
earlier I think it was this summer you
know we went through the four stoic
virtues
um so I would go to that and I at the
very beginning I'm telling you what
sources I'm working from obviously
Seneca talks about it a lot obviously
the two summaries of stoic doctrine that
we have in in
diagonase Laertes book seven and Aries
didymus epitome of stoic ethics
obviously Cicero's on duties you know
where each of the the virtues is being
discussed in in book one those are all
good starting points but is there like
some sort of uh comprehensive list not
really I mean
there's lots and lots and lots of
discussions of temperance itself and of
the other things that you're asking
about like the workings of desire and
aversion or desire as an emotion so you
know
all right Dean Joseph this is an
interesting one which philosopher or
thinker has been unjustly ignored in
history who deserves more attention or
did not generate as much influence as
they could have for some reason or
another literally thousands of of people
many of whom I probably have never heard
of right
um I think you could make a case for
many many philosophers being overlooked
and
it's kind of hard to to say it's also a
matter of overlooked wear right so if
you go to the average
state school or Ivy League school or you
know something in between like Marquette
over here or a four-year liberal arts
college and you're taking an intro to
philosophy class
and somebody introduces you to some
important people guaranteed they're
leaving almost everybody out and they
probably don't know about most of the
other philosophers and I myself you know
probably you know I could name off a
bunch of people who are not given enough
of a look but there's probably way more
in the history of ideas that I don't
know or don't don't know well or only
know the names of
um and I'm somebody who spends a lot of
time in that so I you know that said
um people who are kind of like
overlooked underrated
um John wisdom and analytic philosophy I
think he's a he's a great thinker Iris
Murdoch you know is another one
um
you know Mary Wollstonecraft
um big fan of her and I think that she
is you know very often overlooked
particularly as a virtue ethicist
also in the history of philosophy
there's a lot of women philosophers who
are overlooked primarily because they're
women and then because other people just
don't you know since other people
haven't paid attention to them uh other
people don't pay attention to them
there's this vicious cycle so you know
of those who I've actually read uh
Margaret
um Cavendish very interesting
um
you know uh annistel you know
um
who else I mean
some you know when we talk about the the
Continental rationalists here in the
United States we don't read malbranch
but we should because he's interesting
people don't pay enough attention to
Pascal all they do is they like
circulate quotes from him you know the
heart has a reasons that the reason
doesn't know that's great but read the
rest of the passes and then read you
know the provincial letters and stuff
like that
um I think there's even like big famous
philosophers like Thomas Hobbes or Renee
Descartes where people read them but
they only read like hobbs's Leviathan
and just bits and pieces of it or they
only read Descartes discourse on method
or meditations and they don't read the
other really interesting stuff like his
correspondence or his uh other passions
of the Soul or you know principles of
philosophy or stuff like that and we
could go further and further back you
know I do videos on some of these people
like Al [ __ ] of York I did recently
um I think he's he's well worth checking
out and some of course people rarely
read more than just Pros logian two to
four for their you know ontological
argument stuff but he's got a lot of
really great works Augustine is somebody
who's often quite quite well read
but you know people don't always read
the really interesting stuff like his
discussions of lying in the two
treatises that he has about lying and so
I there's tons and tons of people that I
think
um have been ignored unjustly or justly
I don't I don't know that we have to
worry about that so quite so much
logic what exactly is abductive
reasoning depends on who you ask I mean
good treatments of this exist in Umberto
echo's books
um purse is C.S per Charles Sounders
purse is one of the first people who
brings that up it's also connected to
what we call inference to the best
explanation the idea is that what you're
doing is you are inferring from a fairly
limited amount of information and saying
what would actually explain this you
know let's see if we can come up with a
hypothesis that would make sense out of
this and then you know ideally you'd
want to actually like test the
hypothesis and stuff
all right uh Andy says I'm reading the
Timaeus I think there's an ethic
embedded in the cosmology namely we
should study nature in order to get hold
of reasons so we can harmonize our souls
yeah I wouldn't call that an ethic I
would call that a uh
um ethical proposition you know it's not
an entire ethic on it on its own
um and the Timaeus does bear on some
ethical matters I mean think about again
the platonic tripartite distinction of
the soul and the you know insistence and
the Timaeus that the highest part is
Immortal and the other two parts are
mortal so it's kind of important for
um
for that to be uh you know Incorporated
it would lead you to like saying I gotta
Focus really on the highest part and
don't even worry about the other two
parts not even my thumos you could say
right uh so yeah I mean you can you can
certainly draw some some ethical
propositions or you know motifs out of
the Timaeus
um I mean
the plateness in general thought that it
was worth studying the universe but
studying the universe so that we can
figure out what lies behind or Beyond it
you know
um so yeah James you mentioned the Phila
Kalia did you know much of the recently
deceased kalistos Warren if you so did
you what do you think of them don't
really know him much so you know
uh elionic do you think it's a fair
criticism of Fuko to say he ultimately
ended up making a metaphysics of
epistemate I don't even know what a
metaphysics of epistemae would would be
so I can't really evaluate that Celine
if you come across the works of David
Benatar come across sure red no
um
let's see
Max Montague hope you're having a good
day off the top of your head
in Aristotle's neck and McCain ethics
what would be three things you agree
with what would be three things you
don't buy into so that's that's an
interesting idea I think I'm more or
less buy the doctrine of the mean
properly understood that you know a lot
of what makes something a virtuous
disposition is that it's not just like
the right amount but directed in the way
it's like a habitus a complexes you know
that we build up over time
um I think that he's right to
distinguish in between virtue and vice
this would be in book book Seven
um self-control and lack of self-control
and karate and acracia
um
I think that he is he's um
he's doing a good job in in a lot of the
analyzes of the specific virtues you
know I think that's that's pretty good
as well
what do I disagree with him on well I I
disagree that the contemplative life is
the good life per se and that the active
life is a second best life I actually
agree with the stoics on this who say
that there is the active life the
contemplative life and then the rational
life the logica
bios logic gospios
um
so that's one thing where I disagree
um I also think that his analysis of
friendship along three different lines
it's good but it's a little bit too
restrictive it's hard to see how you get
from the
lower types of friendship into the
full-fledged friendship
that is you know loving the other person
or Wishing Well to them for their own
sake not for the sake of the utility or
pleasure that they provide you with and
that it's only possible for people who
are you know really virtuous
um I also think that his his analysis of
proiracis of choice deliberate Choice
moral choice however we want to
translate that I think that it um
it ends a little bit too early and that
[Music]
um
if you look if you read across the
Aristotelian text this is where you're
reading Aristotle against Aristotle I
think that the nick of McCann ethics
book three
analysis of priorases is too restrictive
and that
um we need to read the rest of what
Aristotle says to understand it is
something more like the will more like
what Epictetus calls priorases or what
some of the other later commentators
will bring up as well you know
foreign
all right
um email account that's pretty generic
can you compare Nietzsche's conception
of the will to power versus
schopenhauer's will do they intend their
Wills to be essentially impersonal or do
they include a personal aspect both of
their Wills have I mean schopenhauer
doesn't think that there's only will
capital w we all have our individual
Wills right
and same thing with Nietzsche you know
my individual will maybe fundamentally
oriented by Will To Power but it's still
my will right it still exists over here
so it's not as if it's all impersonal
the question you know so there's no
essentially impersonal
um and there are of course personal
aspects
um schopenhauer thinks that will and
Nietzsche does also talk this way too at
various points
I think it's a plausible interpretation
that will is metaphysically basic for
both of them and will is ultimately if
not you know simply irrational certainly
not captured within the scope of
rationality
um
but their their understandings of the
will is is not the same I mean
schopenhauer you could say ultimately is
espousing a kind of monism within that
that you know sort of plays itself out
Nature's a pluralist there isn't any
Will To Power per se that's driving
everything
um there are Wills to power that we can
associate under the concept of Will To
Power so
all right uh the bicameral Monk
your series on do Android's Dream of
Electric Sheep was rather enlightening
for me have you ever read any John
Brunner or Peter Watts but he's not New
Wave I've never even actually heard of
either of them so I don't I don't know
about either of them
um Eunice thoughts on the American
writer and intellectual Tony Morrison
and anti-imperialism really haven't read
much of her so I don't have much to say
about her
um
here's a good one from diogenes the
cynic what philosophers can you think of
that you're glad you'll never have to
read again
[Music]
um
I mean it's interesting to begin with so
when would you have had to read them in
you know classes or for doing research
projects and I guess you know
technically speaking I don't know if I
have to ever read another philosopher
again because
um
you know I could stop doing philosophy
now and and just
I don't know I could keep doing videos
but just bullshitting about things I'm
interested in like heavy metal or the
Packers or animals or things like that
so there isn't like an absolute
necessity that I read certain
philosophers
um
and and you know I don't know that I
won't go back to them I mean I find
Bertrand Russell kind of he's a good
stylist but he's often kind of a prick
um and sometimes you know very
dismissive of other people that are way
better than himself
um
who else don't I want to to particularly
read
um
that I got stuck reading
I don't know it's it I mean I'm not a
fan of Quine I had to read a good bit of
him
um but I haven't thought of Quine for
quite a while
um
I guess it'd be mostly like sort of
second-rate kind of tendentious people
um who you know I'll say this there are
some people who have written books that
I've reviewed in Sadler's honest reviews
where I've given them kind of a negative
review and I'm glad I don't have to read
that book again
um
because they you know they they didn't
know what they were talking about or
they're rather tendentious
but I you know not a lot of people come
to mind quite frankly so yeah I don't
have a good good answer to that
um
all right
just skipped a little bit Yasser where
is Marxism in the channel
under marks you got to use the Google
search function I mean this is like
don't ask me to do the work for you
[Music]
um
fitter what is leibniz's principle of
optimality what I'm guessing you mean by
that is something like God makes this as
the best of all possible worlds so he
like thinks through you know what makes
worlds good and then he chooses this one
Bob what does Cartesian foundationalism
foundationalism of the Cartesian sort
where you know foundationalism is saying
we need to have some sort of foundation
some sort of basis that we can have
complete trust in and then we build up
from that
um what is it I mean read discourse uh
um
Parts two through four and you'll you'll
see it at work right there or read the
meditations and you'll you'll see
Cartesian foundationalism being worked
out
view film who was the most influential
philosopher to you I I don't really know
um because I'm not I'm not like a
follower type and although I've been
fortunate to meet a few uh really cool
people over the course of my career it
didn't happen early on so I wasn't like
unduly influenced like a friend of mine
went to Penn State and studied with
Stanley Rosen and you know if you run
into a Stanley Rosen that might become a
very important you know interpreter like
occupying space in your head I didn't
have anybody like that when I was an
undergrad or frankly much in graduate
school you know
so I had professors who I took classes
with and then I had to kind of figure it
out on my own and I didn't have like I
mean I went through phases right and I I
shot videos on most of the phases that I
went through for a while I was like
super into Wittgenstein for a while I
was super into sard for a while I was
super into Nietzsche you know got into
Thomas Aquinas for a while but none of
them were like the person that I saw
everything through I've always been kind
of an Eclectic and a pluralist in many
respects facts you know so
I think of it more as being like instead
of having Just One Mentor who guides me
around I've got a lot of
smart buddies who I hang out with
and chat with and sometimes they
contradict each other you know
um
zainab Buddha uh do you think
Aristotelian thought had a notion of
Rights like modern day human rights
declaration or was it pure Justice
neither uh Aristotle didn't have a
conception of Human Rights like what you
think about the 1949
um uh
U.N Declaration of Human Rights most
likely
um
that's that's a concept that evolved
over time right I mean you could say
that something like
obligations and therefore a kind of
concept of Rights existing in ancient
times in you know say stoicism or in you
know sort of the universalistic
aspects of Christianity which largely
weren't followed by political leaders
but it's really more of a modern thing
but they're you know Aristotle doesn't
think that there's a thing called Pure
justice justice as he tells us in book
five of the nick of McCain ethics is an
equivocal term and it means a whole
bunch of different things and that's why
people get so mixed up about Justice a
lot of the time you know
all right wavy would you say you're more
drawn towards stoicism than epicureanism
if so why
uh because I think the stoics have more
things right than the epicureans do I
mean that's that's pretty
straightforward do I think that Pleasure
and Pain are not good and the bad no and
neither do this the aristotelians or the
platonists or really I mean most people
don't don't really believe that thing
and the epicureans also have like this
if I was going to be a hedonist I would
not be an Epicurean because I don't buy
that resting Pleasures are better than
active Pleasures which is a central
European Central Epicurean idea
um I think the stoics have more things
right than the epicarians do I don't
think they're they're completely right
um but
you know
we're a little bit handicapped too
because we are missing many stoic texts
and we're missing almost all of the
Epicurean texts now that doesn't mean
that we can't learn valuable things from
both of those schools you know think
about anger management right so
philodamus is a great Epicurean
philosopher he has a whole work on anger
which unfortunately we only possess
fragments of because when they tried to
unroll the scroll they they messed it up
in herculine am but what we do have is
pretty great stuff and he talks about
similar things in some of his other
works so you know we can incorporate
things from from different people you
know
all right um
Anthony says are you familiar with
Harbor Moss's public sphere critiques
against it do you have any rules about
the role the internet with the rise of
discourse on platforms like YouTube
Reddit Etc so
um habermas is talking about the public
sphere
from a pretty early point on in his
Works
um and you know it it encompasses a lot
right when you say criticisms or
critiques against it I'm not sure what
is supposed to be a critique against
there being a public sphere that seems
pretty
uncontroversial maybe what you mean is
like critiques against how habermas
thinks it ought to work or what it's in
you know inherent Norms are something
like that but
um
clearly we are in a different situation
now than when habermas was emerging on
the scene right
and beginning to write the voluminous
literature that habermas has has
generated most of which I haven't read
quite frankly
um
so you know we'd have to take the
internet into consideration you know
we're Beyond coffee houses and pamphlets
and radio and television and stuff like
that and now now into an internet era
where
I mean look at what we're doing right
now we're communicating across
continents
um
I I just created this event a while back
and you're here participating in it and
this is you know we're engaging in some
sort of deliberation perhaps right so
um obviously there's going to be some
distinctive things I haven't read what
habermas has said about the internet
because I mean I think the the latest
Thing by habermas
that I've read is stuff from
the uh the 90s
um
I haven't kept on top of of him but I'm
not a habermas guy you know
uh in Schwab good readings for guidance
on making life decisions I mean it
depends on
what kind of life decisions you have to
make I suppose there's probably a whole
literature out there about like making
career decisions or romantic decisions
or medical decisions or deciding where
to live
um
there's no like one-to-one correlation
where there's like a book about how to
decide this sort of thing that I know of
um but reading widely in in people who
consider that so like you know if you
need to make decisions about friendship
maybe reading Aristotle's on friendship
and Cicero's on friendship Aristotle's
Nico McCain ethics books eight nine and
udamian ethics book seven and Cicero's
on friendship and you know
um
seneca's on benefits could be helpful to
you you know depending on what kind of
situations you're you're facing
um
all right jack says still weird to me
there's a philosopher named John wisdom
it's like a lawyer being named Joe
Justice
yeah I mean I I don't know that much
about the guy's biography but I'm sure
there are probably like a whole bunch of
jokes out there from analytic circles in
the 1930s 40s 50s when he was pretty
active that'd be an interesting thing to
check out you know
um
Mason I've heard from Massimo pigliuchi
being a philosophical eclectic will
eventually result in insurmountable
conflicts of ideas have you encountered
that how do you deal with it I mean
that's news to me from Massimo so I I
expect that maybe you've misinterpreted
what he's saying uh because Massimo and
I have
fairly regular conversations and that's
not something that I've heard him say
um
I mean maybe what you have in mind is
that sooner or later you have to take a
a stand and you have to make a choice
but they're not insome insurmountable
conflicts of ideas you surmount them by
making a choice and saying going this
way I'm not going that way
um so that that's how you deal with it
you make your best decision under the
circumstances that you have right
um
back moon what parts of Marx's writings
do you find the most philosophically
insightful what do you think of the
distinction some Mark Scholars make
between his earlier writings and later
writings I think with most philosophers
you can make distinctions between early
and later writings
if only on the trivial uh point of view
of some things happened earlier some
things happen later it's pretty common
to see
um development taking place right
between different eras of a person's
philosophical work
um nobody like begins with all of the
great ideas in their head and then they
just unfold them all at once you know
philosophy is an ongoing practice
so I mean what do I like in Marx
um I mean I think he's right in in
thinking that
um the capitalist way of structuring uh
economic relations does produce social
effects and leads to ideologies that
tend to be supportive of and also
concealing of the mechanisms of
capitalism
um I think that he is right that there
there tends to be a kind of
impoverishment and myopia that goes
along with the these processes and
um I mean Marx is not the only person
obviously to talk about class
Consciousness I mean Aristotle talks
about this way back in the politics that
you know different ideas of Justice
develop depending on whether you're rich
or one of the many or The Virtuous so
I mean I think there's there's a lot to
that and I think some of his ideas about
like exploitation you know are
it strikes me as pretty true all you got
to do is like work in a restaurant and
get to look at payroll and see where all
the money's going uh and uh you know
you're you're going to be fairly
amenable to some of Marx's points you
know I mean I think his like where
history is going turned out to be quite
wrong and false
um but you know most most philosophers
making historical predictions turn out
to be wrong right
oh here's a good run from Eunice
favorite non-craft beer and metal album
so
[Music]
um
I don't have a favorite metal album if
you were going to ask young Greg you
know back in my teens and early 20s
probably would have been Iron Maiden
peace of mind right but
I don't even have a favorite metal group
at this point in time you know I can
tell you like who my big people are Iron
Maiden is among them
um but so is dio and Black Sabbath and
deep purple and Judas Priest and
Motorhead and you know girls school and
tank and
um Raven and we could go on and on and
on and on right and where how do they
fit into the rankings I I don't really
know you know
I will say this
um
later on well actually later on this
weekend we're going to see Michael
schechner group
uh just down the street here and that's
going to be pretty pretty awesome that's
tomorrow night
um and I think it's like it's 50th
anniversary
uh which is pretty pretty cool you know
and then
um
we're seeing wasp and armored Saint
later on this year in November so that's
going to be fun too as well
um non favorite non-craft beer I mean so
we're talking like a big commercial beer
I guess you know I'd be willing to drink
MGD Miller Genuine Draft right
um
most of the beers that I actually like I
guess would be considered craft beers
but you know I kind of grew out of my
early taste about that stuff
uh here's another one from DC stun as a
hundred who's asking a lot of questions
Epictetus says that we should practice
caution and the things that are under
our control why do you think this is
important and can you give an example
yeah so he says we should have practiced
confidence
um towards the things that are outside
of our control taros right and caution
Eula Baya towards the things that are in
our control and all he means there is we
should be careful about what the hell
we're doing because we actually do
control it so
you know you get sick right and
um you could be worried about like all
the things that are going to happen that
are totally out of your control oh I got
a cough here oh I hope I don't have
covid if I get covered maybe it's going
to like destroy my brain and I'll never
be able to work again an Epictetus would
say you don't know any of that stuff
that's totally out of your control
exercise confidence towards that and
what do you actually have control over
how you react how you think about this
stuff exercise caution in relation to
those things make sure that you're not
letting your crazy ideas run away with
you and make you miserable when you
don't have to feel that way that's
exercise and caution which by the way
is one of the stoic um
the good emotions that you can you can
feel
oh here's a good one mendoc favorite
Venom album
um
you know I only had the first three of
them
and I used to listen to them a lot when
I was in in high school
um
and
I mean I'm tempted to stay at war with
Satan because it's got that like totally
episodic thing and the sound production
is a little bit better but actually I
think it's uh I think it's black metal
um it's got some of the my favorite
songs on it you know
all right BM why is Freud still
considered an important reference in
contemporary philosophy in your opinion
he's perhaps the most widely disparaged
figure across multiple academic Fields
so I mean first of all
the disparaging shouldn't really
be a reason why you reject him you
should actually read him and then think
about whether you believe in this stuff
and you should be selective about it you
should be like yeah I think the Oedipus
complex that doesn't work but having
unconscious desires maybe there's
something to that you shouldn't be all
sweeping and you know all or nothing
about that and the fact that a bunch of
psychologists in the present overreacted
against Freud
um because there was so much freudianism
in the past and now they're like it's
all [ __ ] I mean when you hear
somebody saying something like that you
should dismiss them and say Well they're
not a good scholar good researcher right
you you know and why is Freud still
considered an important reference in
contemporary philosophy whose philosophy
where where are you actually seeing a
lot of people referencing Freud other
than a few people in if we're talking
contemporary philosophy a few people in
Continental philosophy most of the
Continental philosophy people are not
talking about Freud very few analytic
philosophy people are talking about him
very few history of philosophy people or
philosophy is a way of life people are
talking about them so I'm not I'm not
sure where you're getting these
premises for your your
question from
um but you know this is one of those
sort of things where you want to
actually read them and see what you
think is valuable and what you think
isn't and read other people who wrote
about them and see what they think is
valuable
all right
um backbone most of my reading has been
in the history of philosophy I've been
interested in getting into more
contemporary analytic philosophy do you
have any recommendations I do not
because I don't do contemporary analytic
philosophy you should ask somebody who
was trained in in that tradition and who
works in that tradition that sort of
question
um I you know I don't really do a lot of
work on on that sort of thing so
all right uh 1.2
1.2 hi doc I'm really interested in
Hegel and the Germans do you think I
need a background in previous philosophy
like the Greeks or rationalists first
certainly wouldn't hurt right
um it's not to say that you have to like
study everything and in perfect sequence
or something like that but you know
given that
um Hegel is certainly very influenced by
Aristotle it wouldn't hurt to know
something about Aristotle hail is also
from this tradition of German idealism
and so you probably do want to know a
little bit about content at least and
maybe ficta and shelling by way of
contrast
um
and then you can and then you can start
working on it you know so
all right uh tal lant says I've read
nausea by Jean-Paul start I found you
did videos on the book and those videos
were a gem thank you that's that's
awesome to read I mean they were very
low production so
you know it was back before I kind of
had a good idea about how to do
um video recording
um but I think that's um
I think that's good so yeah
um I'm happy that I I'd like to go back
to nausea and I actually am kind of
partial to the Lloyd Alexander
translation I know it's not the best
translation but I I do love Lloyd
Alexander and I think it's kind of cool
that
a fiction writer like him thought it was
important to translate that work
um
Alan what do you think about reading a
wide variety of philosophers versus
rereading the same small handful over
and over for those of us without your
prodigious memory I mean why not do
something that's kind of in between why
not have those who you
returned to over and over again but you
also you know
do read some some new ones from time to
time and and by doing that you also
figure out who do I want to go back to
and and reread you know who's who's
worth
reading over and over again and who's uh
you know I I've figured out what they
have to say and I don't need to read
them ever again I think that would that
would be the way to go
uh Petros any advice about a philosophy
Master's thesis I mean
I guess get ready to do a lot of
research and writing you know
um maybe develop a daily discipline for
doing those sorts of things
um
what else don't expect that everybody
else is automatically gonna view what
you're doing is valuable or interesting
so you might want to you know think to
yourself how are you going to explain
what you're studying to people who don't
have the same background or interests
that could be that could be helpful I
suppose
Stepping Razor says I've been doing
self-directed study philosophy the last
few years I'm happy to have recently
stumbled across your channel thank you
for putting out so much solid content oh
the very very welcome I'm glad that
um you have found the videos useful
um
I mean I I enjoy doing this I I probably
will do this for you know at least
another decade I don't know what's going
to happen to YouTube I actually had a
recent scare by the way where our 16
terabyte hard drive that I had hooked up
to my computer upstairs where I do all
the video processing
I um
I didn't realize that you're not
supposed to keep it plugged in all the
time and I did and it failed and that's
where
all the video content has been you know
deployed including not just video
content but podcast content and
fortunately before it failed completely
I copied over my massive like
750 Meg
um
uh or as a gig
um yeah gigabyte of of
[Music]
uh audacity podcast you know projects
and stuff like that and I had done a
backup of my video stuff about a year
and a half ago
um but all the newer stuff was was on
that drive or it's in you know in
YouTube obviously right so holy [ __ ] was
that a wake-up call I was like oh this
is bad I better back this stuff up in
other places you know
all right
um
Eunice thoughts on Cory Anton zealous
you are the sunset spiel
I don't know that I you know I have not
been paying very close attention to
Corey Anton even though he's just across
Lake Michigan from me so
silent mandible have you read Hagel and
the Hermetic tradition I read enough of
it to realize that I wasn't interested
in it and put the book down
um
English is easier can you discuss W.B
Yates Byzantium in Easter 1916. nope
I'm not a poetry analysis guy
Oscar Cooper what philosophy books do
you recommend for depression I'm
currently doing therapy and having meds
well I don't have any specific
recommendations
um
I would say that it you know it could be
useful for you to study
some
um stoic philosophy you know it's not
going to be a cure-all but it can
certainly help you out in terms of
thinking about your thought processes
um there is actually a really there was
a great book I read by a reporter who
suffered from depression about
depression
and
I think it was called I'm working it up
right now lost connections yeah
um by Jonathan Hari I actually liked
that a good bet I think it could be
useful to read that
um that reminds me actually I need to go
back and do like a update of the video
that I did like 10 years ago about
philosophy and depression
um but you know I would just like read
around and don't expect too much out of
any particular work just look for tools
that you can use is probably uh the best
thing that you could do for yourself
all right Scott Kent
um
I'm in a phenomenology class this
semester most of our readings are from
Maryland Ponte and some other
contemporary phenomenologists just
curious how do you feel about
phenomenology in general I don't feel
anything about phenomenology in general
because there is no such thing as
phenomenology in general there is a vast
phenomenological tradition that includes
many different people many different
approaches I like Marlo Ponte I'm also a
huge fan of Mark Shaler obviously I like
Heidegger edit Stein I like a good bit
um Paul recruit is another favorite guy
of mine but I I also like Heidegger tend
to think of a lot of people that we
don't call phenomenologists as if
they're doing something like a
phenomenology like I think that
Aristotle's Nick of McCann and udamian
ethics are a phenomenology of moral life
you know
they don't cover everything so when
phenomenology becomes a very rigid you
must do it this way kind of method I'm
not really cool with that but as a way
of providing us insight about stuff I
think it's actually pretty valuable as
as an approach so
uh Ryan how is your relationship to
Christianity or Catholicism changed over
the years or any philosophical readings
particularly influential
yeah philosophical readings and literary
readings I would say I mean I came back
to the church in part through Reading
great Christian philosophers who worked
on me over time you know like Anselm and
Aquinas and Maurice Blondell
um Mark Shaler too I just mentioned a
little bit earlier
but literature played a big role too you
know reading Graham green
flanner Flannery O'Connor
um
to a lesser extent evelynwa you know
um people say that bride said Revisited
is the best Catholic novel of the 20th
century I disagree I say that Graham
greens the power and the glory actually
is
um
you know so you know thinkers like that
influenced me
um I would say that when it comes to
like the American institutional church I
think that it's pretty rotten
um and unfortunately a lot of
um
originally Conservative Catholics
have become captivated by the cultured
war and essentially colonized by the
Republican party and they're effectively
not not Christian anymore even though
they talk all the time about
Christianity in the church and culture
and stuff like that I think they're
actually Antichrist rather than
Christians
um
and so that's that's rather
disappointing to see you know the
institutional church is a mess I mean
the the good news is if you know
anything about church history it's
always a mess right the bad news is if
you know anything about church history
it's always a mess so
um
yeah I mean you you work out your your
life one of the best things that I've
seen uh about you know
the church was in an interview with
Aleister McIntyre after he became a
Catholic and he it was you know from
somebody from our University Southern
Illinois University it was published in
canases in this famous interview with
him and they said why why do you go to
the the Catholic Church what what it
attracts you to that and I think the
interviewer was expecting him to say
something like oh well I was convinced
by Arguments for the existence of God or
you know this vast cultural Reservoir
and McIntyre looked at him like he was
stupid and he said because that's where
the sacraments are another guy said you
know would you like to elaborate what
the hell is there to elaborate
that's a that's a great great uh quip by
McIntyre I think
all right
um
Fire Emblem 27 if God himself were to
become a man in today's world and saw
the state of the world do you think he
would deny his own existence no I I
don't think so
um that one's easy to answer
uh maximum I'm currently reading fear
and trembling by Kierkegaard I find it a
tough read but I'm enjoying it very much
which work of Kierkegaard do you
recommend F okay so that's going in a
different direction I thought it was
going to
[Music]
um
you know
I would actually say philosophical
fragments and as it so happens I got
seven hours of video I think on that
that text walking through it
um because you know the stuff that
you're going to see in there about the
ethical and the religious and the
teleological suspension or the ethical
and you know the connections between
these
gets worked out
in that but you could say from the
perspective of
a philosopher who is explicitly not a
Christian but is considering it as a
hypothesis in a in a way so that would
be a good one
um Vincent Andrew your thoughts on
Simone Vay and mice Meister Eckhart both
interesting Meister Eckhart tends to be
oh I would say a bit overrated by people
who read his stuff and they're they're
of the hippy dippy oh wow Deep Thoughts
man kind of stuff
um I actually did have a good friend in
graduate school who did his master's
thesis on Eckhart and so he had me work
with him on translating some of the the
sermons and stuff like that and I kind
of I get where Eckhart was going
um I'm just not attracted to that sort
of mysticism myself
um
neoplatonus what do you think happened
to the philosophical way of life why do
you think many philosophers today study
the discipline yet live lives like
regular people
uh because that's normal
you know
um
look look throughout history
Spinoza had a job they card had jobs you
know Aristotle uh eventually founded a
school but he had jobs along the way and
had a lot of respect for you know the
kind of work that people did and living
lives
um stoics uh you know did work so the
question is whether we can transform our
ordinary life by bringing philosophical
insights to it
I don't think that you need to live a
special philosophical kind of life
uh guy does Hegel really have a concrete
well-defined epistemology I can explain
the basics of concept epistemology Hegel
seems a lot softer don't know what
softer means
um
I don't I mean a concrete well-defined
epistemology I don't know that Kant has
a concrete well-defined epistemology it
all depends on what those those terms
mean
um Hagel is certainly interested in
knowledge but you got to kind of like
read all over the place to get what his
his take on it is don't you so
yeah
um
now I can't read Cyrillic stuff so I
don't know what this person's name is
what do you think about empirical
philosophy it is even possible to
practice does philosophy have to be done
in armchair is there a place for on
Plein Air philosophy I would say that
dichotomy that you're setting up is
probably unproductive
um
whenever you are tempted to dismiss
something as armchair philosophy you
probably want to look more closely at it
because it's probably not just what
you're you're pitching that way and
obviously philosophers engage with
empirical things all the time so yeah
um kazaza Dan I'm currently studying
philosophy in the UK in a couple years
they'll be eligible to study abroad one
of my options is Wisconsin Milwaukee
wondering if you have any thoughts on
the uni so I mean you can study here
Milwaukee is a great town UW Milwaukee
has been
um you know dealing as has the entire UW
system with the damage that was done
under the Republican administration of
Scott Walker
um and you know if if we happen to elect
that jackass Tim Michaels who's not even
actually from Wisconsin he's from
Connecticut
um then it's going to get even worse
here and I wouldn't consider any
anything within the UW system if that
turns out to be the case
um
there are some decent people at
uw-milwaukee the department has shrunk a
bit
um
I I haven't interacted with too many of
them
you know I will say this that the former
chair and I'm very glad that he's gone
uh told me that the stuff that I do
doesn't isn't really philosophy at all
so that kind of gives you an idea about
where at least some of their their
mindsets are
um so yeah all right uh
let's see column was best armchairs to
philosophize from well I mean I'm in an
armchair right here you know my my wife
uh who's very good at finding Bargains
got us this entire
um set with you know two armchairs and a
nice couch
um so this is this is a pretty good one
I I don't know what the best one is you
know
so
Alec a lot of young people's
introduction to philosophy is through
Marx or Marxism have you yourself
studied either at length do you find
them particularly useful I wonder where
that is where most where a lot of young
people's introduction of philosophy
would be through marks or Marxism
I mean
that does not ring a bell to me
[Music]
um
that must be some some other country
right that that the idea is coming from
uh if I studied either Marx and Marxism
yeah obviously I mean I've taught Marx
in the past I've got videos on on marks
do I find them particularly useful sure
for the things that they're useful for
if you want to I mean if if your goal is
to like understand
um Aesthetics obviously Marx is not
going to tell you much about it but
there are marxists like you know the
Frankfurt School people who can say
interesting things about it or Bach teen
you know uh great uh Soviet theorists
um he's got some some stuff to say about
novels at least and art
so it depends on what you're what you're
looking for you know
um
silent mandible do you have any opinions
on Mao's work on dialectics and
contradiction
no I mean I read through some of that
stuff about a year and a half ago
because I had a tutorial client
who is actually a leninist Marxist who
wanted to
work on
some of that stuff but I don't I don't
remember enough other than like thinking
yeah this might be worth going back to
down the line but no time for it so
all right Lord Roku
um
are you aware of any other pyronian
works except sexist um outline of
pyromism no
um but there's plenty of skeptical works
so Cicero his
um on the ends
um book five
um
on the nature of the Gods book three
all of the academica is worth checking
out
um
who else in ancient philosophy I mean
you have diogenes Laertes
talking about
um pyro he's got a life of pyro so that
could be useful
struggling to think about I mean I know
there's other stuff out there but I
don't remember offhand who you would you
would look at
um
so back to the Cyrillic thing Marx is
very influential thinker among
contemporary youth where I mean not here
um
Warwick school really popularized Marx
and critique of capitalism
I'm sure what I mean whatever you say
um I I don't see that reflected all that
much in things and and the Warwick
school I mean there's like hundreds and
hundreds of schools all over the place
we could say you know the Duquesne
school is popularized hegelianism again
but how much does that really mean right
so I I don't I don't know
um
looks like I'm actually like on track
for answering at least the majority
of the questions
uh we're getting close to the end of our
90 minutes or so so
let's see what else people have and I'll
address as many of them as I can I got
about another
um
five minutes left or so and uh we can
discuss whatever whatever else is coming
up doesn't have to be philosophy it
could be more music stuff I've got to
get to another event
um a little bit later on today a
philosophy chat for patreon supporters
and then
got a conversation with a friend then I
got a tutorial then I'm having dinner
with my wife and her mother
and then I got to shoot a whole bunch of
video on Philip K dick tonight all right
Lord Roku your thoughts on neoplatonic
metaphysics is it still applicable today
uh yeah I mean if it if it was
applicable in ancient times and it was
true it would be applicable today but
with Neil platonism you got to say who's
neoplatonism right it's not as if
there's a single
thinker that everyone's like that's the
neoplatonism I'm talking about man you
know there's Jewish neoplatonism like
phyllo of Alexandria there's all sorts
of Christian neoplatonists you know
Augustine being one of them a lot of
these Church fathers being Christian
neoplatonists there's Pagan
neoplatonists although they're not Pagan
in the old sense where they think that
like Zeus actually screwed around on
Hera or stuff like that they got sort of
a purified you know uh conception of the
gods that would be like platinus and
simplicious and um
you know those people as well
so it really depends on Whose
neoplatonism were thinking about
um am I into Joy Division I'm not really
into Joy Division myself my wife is more
as well as new order but we did see
Peter hook uh
uh not that long ago and I enjoyed
seeing the guy on stage
um also playing with his son
interestingly as the Peter hook plays
the bass but he plays it as a solo
instrument uh and then his son was the
bassist for the actual band as well
bismala so I'm guessing because I I've
heard of destiny that these other people
are YouTubers Destiny Hassan ABI rethim
both boy I I don't know who any of them
are
um I you know I've heard Destiny
mentioned in in
um Twitter but I I don't really follow
these people I don't really watch a lot
of people's videos frankly you know
um in part because I don't have the time
and
I'm I'm a video producer I'm not really
a video consumer you know I'd rather
read books than that
um mndoc read any good science fiction
lately yeah so I mean I'm rereading
Philip K dick
for the worlds of speculative fiction of
this month which is focused on Androids
and humans and then I um people kept you
know pestering me to do the Dan Simmons
Hyperion cantos and uh I'm close to
finishing the fall of Hyperion
and
um
I'm I'm really enjoying it at first I
thought that was kind of hokey you know
we're all gonna tell a story about our
lives you know Canterbury Tales rip off
once again but it's it's pretty
compelling it's it's it's great fiction
um what else about have I been reading
lately you know I really did appreciate
reading the Ballard JG Ballard stuff
that I did for the previous worlds of
speculative fiction
um
other fiction
I mean I really haven't had that much
time for reading too much other fiction
lately so I I don't think I don't think
I've read too much
um queer to you what kind of music do
you listen to well you know
the hottest band in the world
kiss
I I'm I listen to a lot of classic metal
I also listen to a lot of other things
as well you know I'm a big fan of like
Duran Duran and New Model Army and PJ
Harvey and I've got kind of eclectic
taste but they tend towards the heavy
and the hard and the driving and you
know that that sort of thing
although you know I I do like going to
the uh Milwaukee Symphony Orchestra and
listening to classical music usually
with my wife sometimes with my wife and
her mom
um so there's there's that aspect as
well
you know
um
yeah that's a good place to end I would
say looks like we got through most of
the questions so
thanks everybody for all your questions
and comments those of you who you know
enjoy the YouTube videos I'm glad that
people do enjoy them and we do these
every month we've got a couple other
events coming up uh this month that I'll
just throw out there stoicon of course
I'm the emcee for that happening on
October 29th end of the month the big
International online stoic conference
I'm also giving a talk
um on stoicism and their weird
conceptions of the virtues namely that
there is no mean whatsoever between
virtue and vice and is this really
plausible I'm giving that at Marquette
University on the 19th but it will be
broadcast uh over Microsoft teams as
well
we've got worlds of speculative fiction
next weekend
and there's something else and I can't
remember what the hell oh you got stoic
week right the big stoic week is
beginning on the 24th
um I'm not you know I'm affiliated with
X I'm part of the modern stoicism team
but I'm not I'm not the one in charge of
that this year and stoicism today
selected essays volume 4 is going to be
coming out fingers crossed fate willing
uh later on this month as well so that
should be kind of cool so all right I'll
see all of you somewhere else in the
ether and talk to you later